Well, Brandon,
man, congratulations.
You just came off a
huge win against two
formidable opponents,
which means you're still
in contention for the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and that
check for $10,000.
But in order to
take home the win,
you've got a lot of
work ahead of you
because you're
going to have to go
against an undefeated
opponent who
has a lot of experience
in this forge,
and that guy is Ben Abbott.
BRANDON FRANKLIN: I've been
preparing for this competition,
but Brendan seems to be
a very talented smith.
You guys will have
eight hours to build
a blade from start to finish.
Brandon, you had
the opportunity
to choose what blade
and what technique
you're both going to use.
So you've got a little
bit of an upper hand here.
But Ben, you ready to find
out what you're building?
Yeah, let's do it.
The weapon that Brandon chose
from the "Forged in Fire" vault
is the messer.
DOUG (VOICEOVER): The
messer traces its origins
back to 15th century Germany.
While these swords
range in size,
they are distinguished by the
intricate hilts and guards.
Back in season six
of "Forged in Fire,"
two smiths were tasked to
recreate a massive version
of this weapon, where the
competition ultimately
went to the lighter,
better balanced blade.
Smiths, you have eight hours
to complete your messer swords,
and that time starts now.
Going up against
Ben, being 4 and 0,
I really hope that I'm
the one to beat him.
I've got my tip roughly
where I want it.
And then I go over and create
this subtle distal taper.
A lot of bladesmiths
grind to it,
but I definitely want to
set myself up for less
work later on at the grinder.
When I'm doing some
thermal cycling,
I want to work on that guard.
Do a quick test fit, and
it fits up the first time.
And it's just this
huge sense of relief.
HOST: Brandon's getting
ready for his quench.
BRANDON FRANKLIN: We're
at a point of no return.
If I break this blade, I
could not finish this blade.
I see a nice straight blade.
And then its end of
the tempering oven.
I'm really nervous about fitting
this handle up because I know
with the multiple
components going on,
it's going to eat
up a lot of my time.
I'm kind of struggling
with the pin,
so I've got to be careful here.
I could risk cracking
my handle material.
Luckily hitting it with a
hammer was enough to drive it
home where it needed to be.
But I still have to
sharpen this thing too.
So now I really need
to move it up a gear
and get this thing done.
Time is ticking away.
And if I turn in a dull
blade, I'm going home.
I'm really putting all my eggs
in the basket of this damascus
because it's going
to take a long time.
But I think at the
end of the day,
the pattern is going
to be gorgeous,
and I'm going to end
up with a keen edge
that will hopefully not get
damaged in the strength test.
There's a madness to my method.
I've never seen a bigger
billet getting weld set
on this "Forged" floor.
Holy cow.
I start to panic.
It's so tall, I can't get
the compression that I
need all the way through.
Instead of going to
blue at this point,
I have to go to the press.
It feels like my
billet is together now.
Yeah, it's good.
I finally started
working on a blade.
That's the first
one in the oil.
And I can see the terror
in Brandon's eyes.
It looks straight.
I'm happy.
I'm going for a relatively fine
edge on this because 80 CRV 2
can hold its shape pretty well.
I've never made a
guard like this before.
You make the guard
all in one piece.
And then you have this side
guard that has a tang to it,
and you pin it over
on the far side.
One of the things
I know as a judge
is that the handle
has to be comfortable.
But there are spots
on this handle
I can't get to with the grinder
because the knuckle bow is
there or the side
guard is there.
In all the times that I
competed on this competition,
this one's been
more difficult. I
think it's because I
invested so much time
up front working on the blade.
So, at this point, the only
thing I can think to do
is grab a hand file and
work with a hand file.
My heart is beating
out of my chest.
I might not finish this thing.
5, 4, 3, 2, 1.
Bladesmiths, turn
off your machines.
Put down your tools.
This eight-hour
competition is over.
All right guys, we
are finally here.
And there's a lot on the line.
Ben, if you take
home the win, you're
continuing your winning
streak, and going
on with a record of 5 and 0.
Now Brandon, if you
take home the win,
you're leaving here with the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and a
check for $10,000.
In order for us to find out
which one of your blades
is going to come out
on top, we have to put
them through a series of tests.
So I'm going to give you
to Doug for the first one.
Bladesmiths, this is
the dynamic kill test.
To find out how lethal
your weapons are,
we take your swords,
cut through the vines,
and deliver some lethal
blows on this pig carcass.
It's time to have fun.
[music playing]
All right, guys.
First up, the
handle construction,
it's a little bit
on the blocky side.
But it's comfortable.
Why?
Because it's light.
Every cut, every one of them was
very deep on this pig carcass.
Overall, this eight-hour
master sword, it will KEAL.
I'm pretty confident that my
sword is not going to break.
But something might chip,
something might roll.
Anything is possible.
I'm, I'm just nervous.
[music playing]
So right off the bat, I
really appreciate the flare
on a heavier blade
like this because it
does allow me to control it.
The weight of this
cuts very deep.
It thrusts nicely and
delivers all the way out.
A blade like this, it will KEAL.
All right, gentlemen,
a little bit of history.
In 1570, Joachim
Meyer's treatise
on the use of the dussack
was published, the training
manual for the messer.
So we know that it
was used by peasant
soldiers as well as nobility.
So to that end, our
dynamic strength test.
Gentlemen, I'll be
taking your messers
and attacking our
armored warrior here.
After that, we'll
see what kind of edge
you have left by
slicing that painting.
You guys ready?
- Oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
DAVE BAKER: OK.
[music playing]
All right.
So right off, it's
taken a couple of rolls
that I can feel with
the fingernail, and then
a couple of small minor chips.
But for hitting armor,
that's not so bad.
All in all, our gold
anvil did a good job.
[music playing]
All right.
So as far as the edge
goes, nothing's come off
and nothing's
really rolled over.
So all in all, I think the red
anvil did a really nice job.
Now guys, the
judges had a very
difficult decision to make.
And they came up
with a final decision
that they both agreed upon.
The winner of this "Forged
in Fire" competition
is Ben Abbott with
the red anvil.
Congratulations.
No way.
Now Brandon, you absolutely
smoked this competition.
But unfortunately, your messer
didn't make the cut today,
and Dave Baker is
going to tell you why.
Brandon, you did a
great job on that messer.
It's fast and it's deadly.
This basically came down to
damage and some design choices.
Fair enough.
I can honestly say you're
one of the most talented smiths
I've ever laid my eyes on.
Thank you.
We appreciate all of your
hard work in this competition.
But unfortunately, I'm going
to have to ask you to please
step off the forge floor.
Thank you for the time, guys.
Thank you.
Good job, man.
Awesome work.
Thanks, man.
Today just wasn't my day.
But I think I turned in an
absolute phenomenal blade
that stacked up against one
of the best, Ben Abbott.
All right, Ben.
You did it.
Your messer took
home the win again.
You're now 5 and 0, man.
Congratulations.
This was an extremely
close competition.
Brandon is a hell
of a competitor.
He made a really
good messer sword.
And I was actually practicing my
happy faced concession speech.
You ready for more?
Yep.
Let's do it.
Any bladesmiths that
want to come in here
and challenge me in my own
house, I'm here, ready for you.